it's great to be joined today by Nathan
J Robinson who's the editor of current
affairs author of several books
including the current affairs rules for
life and Trump anatomy of a monstrosity
we'll talk first a little bit about our
newest Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh Nathan you write in an article
which I found very interesting that
there's sort of another whole set of
issues here that are separate from the
sort of adjudication of what happened
with dr. Christine Blasi Ford and other
women years ago which is the fact that
Brett Kavanaugh has lied a bunch of
times during the most recent and prior
hearings and that regardless of the
truth or falsity of the sexual assault
claims that alone is a very good reason
for him not to be on the court so talk a
little bit about how you sort of
conceived of this article yeah it was a
lot to me because the focus of a lot of
the discussion was on figuring out
whether Brett Kavanaugh had in fact
assaulted Christine Blasi Ford and
whether there was enough evidence and
what the standard of proof should be and
all is important but there was another
issue which is that when you looked at
evanov testimony a lot of the things he
said were simply manipulative or untrue
and Regatta and if that's the case if
it's the case that a judge who is under
oath and is testifying before the Senate
says things that are not true or
misleads the Senate that really should
end the issue it's a it's a it's very
serious right so as I looked through the
testimony I thought well people aren't
zeroing in on some of the really
important ways in which Cavanaugh
misrepresented the truth and if if if we
just discuss that if it's provable and I
think it is provable then it doesn't
matter if you prove the allegations or
not because he should be disqualified in
his I want to talk about Republicans in
a second first we'll talk about how
Democrats handled this Bernie Sanders
did write a letter where he said he
wanted the potential perjury stuff
looked into but beyond that tell me if
I'm wrong I didn't really see a
clamoring from from Democrats in general
to focus in on the fact that the guy
appears to have lied no I think I think
and I think this was a mistake I think
Democrats spent a lot of the hearings
pushing for an FBI investigation which
they should have known would be flimsy
at best and and I think they they truck
they got caught up in this question of
who what happened that night in nineteen
in the early eighties and what what did
Brett Kavanaugh do this and you know
making the argument that he the the
evidence was sufficient to where he
should be up the court and they didn't
as I say they didn't focus in on the
fact that he misrepresented a number of
crucial things right he said that all of
the people that Christine Ford says were
there said the event didn't happen well
that's just false one of them says she
actually believes Ford uh he said that
he never attended an event with the
people that she alleges he the event was
with and if you look the calendars that
he submitted as evidence he did in fact
an attended event the calendars he yeah
there was this awful one where he said
it was asked about the way bass made fun
of this girl in high school and sort of
suggested that she slept around and he
said oh no we never never suggested that
well it's actually very very clear that
they did they even wrote a poem about
how easy she was and and there are other
students now have come out and said no
he was lying about that it was they were
definitely making fun of her about sex
and and and he denied it under oath and
and you can't do that you shouldn't be
able to do that if you're a federal
judge so on the one hand I agree that
Democrats did sort of make this mistake
by pushing for the FBI investigation
into sort of the the idea of
adjudicating what did or didn't take
place in the early 80s at the same time
that was the only thing that even
delayed the confirmation the week that
it did if I I think that there's a
possibility that if they focus from the
beginning on the possible perjury that
you don't even get a delay and he ends
up going
firmed even earlier yeah but the timing
of his confirmation doesn't matter that
much if he's going to be confirmed I
mean I I think he was going to be
confirmed no matter what the question is
do you what what can you do when you
know that they have the votes to confirm
him and I think first I think you would
have had a higher chance of getting some
of the quote moderate Republicans to be
a little wary er about confirming him if
you had preferred gone hard on the it's
provable that he said things that were
not true angle I think I think that
would be harder for them to deal with
they had an FBI investigation to point
to to cover their vote they can't really
do that so much if you if you just lay
out the perjury thing before the
American public very very clearly and
it's also a really good way of building
clear public support and and and I think
it's really hard for Republicans to
defend there is a mechanism through
which as a Supreme Court justice he
could be removed or impeached and it
requires a majority of the house and
two-thirds of the Senate Democrats may
well have a majority in the house
starting in January depending on the
results last less than four weeks from
now two-thirds of the Senate is is not
going to happen and quite frankly I just
don't see any way in which even if you
prove that that he lied that you get
whatever number you need 14 or however
many Republicans to say yeah we're gonna
go ahead with this yeah you're not
actually going to get him impeached and
removed from office I think if you do
emphasize impeachment and you use that
as a sort of slogan you're doing it not
because you think you can actually get
it done but because it's important to
make clear that he's not a legitimate
Supreme Court justice that he ought to
you know it calls into question all of
his rulings he's always kind of a
justice with an asterisk next to his
name and and the American people come to
see him as a Justice who ought to be
removed and you shouldn't emphasize the
impeachment what you should emphasize is
the the fact that he warrants
impeachment that this is a guy who
really in if we were evaluating
in a sort of fair-minded manner she just
shouldn't be on the court and if you can
build public consensus around that that
that really helps the Democratic Party
to make its case in elections that the
that they are the ones who are going to
who are going to treat the court as it
should be treated does it though because
while I agree with you on the politics
and the underlying analysis it's not
going to really successfully be done in
advance of this November and then do you
really think that pushing the fact that
Cavanaugh lied during his 2018 hearings
would help Democrats in 2020 like I just
think people will have forgotten about
it and they won't care no not not on its
own but I think as part of an X you have
to build everything into part of it into
a narrative and and narratives are what
win elections and this is a small part
of the narrative that American the
Democrats should be thinking well what
is going to show people oh that we are
right and that we ought to be voted for
and I think saying look Republicans will
put a perjurer on the court if it helps
further their political agenda and they
don't actually care about their
principles and values and use that as
one in a series of examples of that I
think that can actually be persuasive no
I don't think impeach Cavanaugh should
be the slogan for 2020 oh but I don't
think you should let it go because I
think it is a pretty powerful thing and
it's pretty easily provable so the
narrative and the values are something I
want to touch on next with you from a
sort of cultural perspective it's it's
abundantly clear to me and to many who
have been following the so-called
value-based politics of the American
Republican Party for a while that the
values aren't real values they're
basically ways to get people to either
donate to you or to vote for you like
abortions always been a great example
which is we know how to reduce the
number of abortions but Republicans
don't want to do it because it doesn't
it doesn't fall in line with their
values which is access to contraception
comprehensive sex education etc here
they've been able to say that even
though it appears as though the alleged
actions of Cavanaugh might go against
their stated values the value that they
are defending
is innocent until proven guilty you've
not definitively proven his guilt and
thus it is in line with their values to
say we can't stop him from being on the
court do you agree that this is like one
of the most successful elements of the
American right which is no matter what
happens they can craft a narrative that
appears to fit into their stated values
well they're brilliant at doing politics
I mean I I have to give them credit they
always win I mean they've been winning
all around the country all the state
legislatures even in blue states are
falling state governorships
the other they're excellent at selling
people or on this these phony values
whether it is as you say abortion where
it's like well most women say that they
get abortions partially for economic
reasons they can't afford a child and it
you're not gonna have paid family leave
policies or whether it's this until
proven guilty thing which it's
interesting because you never hear about
innocent it's the ACLU and and the
public defenders who are always talking
about the horrors of the criminal
justice system of what happens when
people are accused and tried without
without due process yeah it falls apart
under under scrutiny because you say
okay well innocent until proven guilty
sure but what if we think there's a
twenty percent chance that this guy did
it would you be comfortable in putting
that person on the court if you think
there's any chance that he did it that's
reasonable or you know look at the
perjury um but they say it it's catchy
and they're good at pushing it innocent
until proven guilty how do you oppose
innocent until proven guilty no
corroborating evidence and that's kind
of persuasive people they go oh yeah no
corroborating evidence innocent until
proven guilty so yeah we need to get
better at politics I've been reading
some very interesting books on law
enforcement and police interrogation
because I think there's a lot of
analogies there to political debate
interestingly enough and one of the
points I see made it made time and time
again is when you're trying to persuade
someone of something whether it's to can
to a crime or to see your your point of
view on a political issue whatever we
tend to argue on the basis of our values
rather than the values of the person
that we're trying to persuade and so
you're talking about economic inequality
in terms that resonate to the left won't
necessarily influence somebody on the
right because they might just have two
totally different values so do you have
a sense and you can pick a particular
political issue or we can talk about the
cabinet I think oh really whatever way
you want to go what are some ways that
the left can appeal to the rights values
without sort of giving up their their
position on what they see as the
important values either if that makes
sense
well you know I would actually take the
opposite approach I think you got to be
very careful about not III I've read an
article called don't I think don't base
left-wing arguments on right-wing
premises interesting and I and I talk a
lot about things like where you adopt
the rights values and I think it's
actually a mistake a lot of the time to
try and make the case for left-wing
ideas without making the case for
left-wing values and saying one of the
examples of this that I that I use is
that everything is phrased in terms of
saving money well this will make and we
the left often talks about criminal
justice like this while you know the
death penalty for example is really
expensive it costs a lot of money and
it's a well so if you if you want the
government to save money you should
oppose the death penalty now really
that's not why we oppose the death
penalty on the Left we oppose it because
we we don't think the state has should
be killing people who don't pose the
threat anymore but we say it saves money
well you know first there's not even a
very persuasive argument because a good
way to save money is to like execute
people immediately after trial which I'm
sure get rid of all the appeals but also
you know it's when you make a case that
is on grounds that are not the real
reason that you support a thing you can
sound kind of dishonest and I actually
think it's much harder to make the case
for left-wing values when people don't
share those values but
I think you shouldn't be trying to
persuade people who have committed and
unyielding conservative principles and
say well actually our policies you know
follow conservative principles what do
you do right because if if your values
are different than their so they're
certainly not going to come around to
your values and at the same time you
shouldn't show how there might be a way
in which your values and their values
could lead you down to the same policy
in the end then what do you do well the
question is who you're talking to
right and the fact is that more people
don't vote than vote for either one of
the two parties so I don't think you
should be I don't think you should cast
your appeal to people who have
inflexible conservative values you
should be trying to talk to people who
do kind of share your underlying
sympathies or could be brought around to
it but are not particularly politically
active the fact is that you know left
values I happen to think are shared by
the majority of people I think I think
polling data kind of suggests that I
think most people are generally
empathetic and can be precise I would
prefer to try and sell people on my
understanding of your criminal justice
rehabilitation which is that like I
believe in people and I think people
need second chances than to try and
persuade people on a cost saving
argument I there are people that I can't
convince with that because they'll just
dismiss me out of hand but there are
other people who will be more persuaded
by that because they'll understand that
I'm being honest and I'm present this is
why people like this is why a lot of
people like Bernie Sanders even if
they're less that there's a group of
people who are even people who vote kind
of conservative who will respect Bernie
Sanders more than they respect say
Hillary Clinton because they think well
I disagree with him more but he's more
honest and so I trust him more that's a
good place to pause we are speaking with
Nathan J Robinson editor of current
affairs author of several books and
tomorrow we will continue our
conversation with him about the
intellectual dark web so called as I say